listening to phil
courage women
and carry me away
and I've read a lot about this online
that the distribution models are really
changing now we're something that i
think peter broderick talks about is
hybrid distribution which is basically
spreading out your rights as much as you
can sense that you know sell it yourself
which we've learned sell it sell it you
know either through your own website or
companies like film baby that you know
you can do easy sales off of and then
sell other rights to you know domestic
distributors but basically spread it out
as much as you can because as marshaller
off says it's the the distribution
industry is designed most most companies
business model is designed around the
idea that you have to sue them to get
your money there and I've heard this
from virtually everybody's eighty ninety
percent of distributors out there are
extremely dishonest and do a lot of
creative accounting and so getting
distribution isn't necessarily a good
thing I think that's the that's a trick
everybody wants to get distribution for
their film but it doesn't really mean
anything really because a lot of times
it just means you're going to get
screwed well and the number one thing
that we have learned is the most
important thing you can get out of a
distributor is in advance because that's
likely the only money you're ever going
to see they're not willing to give you
an advance and or sizeable enough
advance and they're taking away most of
your rights there's virtually no reason
to do that deal unless like I said
you've done your due diligence there an
extraordinarily honest company they do
return money to the filmmaker over time